Travis, as we said right before the commercial,
we have someone very special standing by,
that's a huge fan of yours and if it's okay,
do you mind standing by?
Of course.
Okay, Marcel Desobeau is a firefighter paramedic
and a huge fan of Travis's.
He and his seven-month old little one, daughter Lane,
have gone viral for their hilarious
and very sweet drumming videos on TikTok
and everybody's obsessed, take a look.
(Heavy metal music)
Please welcome Marcel Desobeau
and his daughter Lane.
(audience applauding)
How's it going Drew?
Oh, hi!
(Marcel laughs) This is Lane.
Oh hi Lane and so nice--
Say hi.
To meet you, Marcel.
Marcel, I am so excited, (Lynn coos)
we're obsessed with your videos.
How did this all start?
Oh, thank you.
Yeah, actually, we were just hanging out
at the kitchen table one morning
and I just randomly said, hey, let's make a video.
We were just having fun,
at the kitchen table and sure enough, here we are.
Well, I see that you're inspired by drumming
and I understand you're a fan of Travis Barker as well.
Oh yeah, for sure.
Travis Barker's awesome.
I've always, always listened to him, right?
Well, if it's okay,
do you mind if I bring him in for a second?
What, really?
Yeah.
Oh My God, how's it going man?
(audience applauding)
That video is awesome.
Ah, thank you so much, man.
You're such an inspiration for me.
I'm kind of lost for words right now,
but thanks for being on the show.
(Marcel laughs, baby coos)
No, you guys are awesome.
I did the same thing with my kids.
(Travis laughs)
They'd be like, what are you doing?
(Travis chuckles)
That's so awesome.
And obviously, thank you for all your services and stuff,
that's awesome.
Oh, thanks man.
I'm happy to do my job.
I really love it.
It's fun.
And I love hanging out with this little one.
(Lane coos)
Marcel, not only are you an amazing father,
but you're on the front lines as a paramedic
and a firefighter.
How is everything right now in your amazing heroic world?
Oh, it's going great.
Yeah, obviously the COVID thing happened last year
and things got a little difficult,
the world can't stop because of COVID.
(Lane coos)
We have to keep going and we have to keep helping people
and that's what I enjoy doing.
And that's what I'm gonna continue to do every day.
Travis, you and I are parents,
that seems like one happy kid, I have to say.
Yes, I live for that, I'm with my kids to have it back.
So I can't even imagine, it's beautiful.
Oh, thank you so much.
She just seems to love these sticks.
I got her, her own little drumsticks, they're pink.
(Marcel laughs)
Oh, that's so cool.
Any tips Travis for Lane?
(Drew laughs)
So I started playing drums when I was three or four
and we couldn't afford a drum kit,
but we just had pots and pans.
And that was my drum set for years,
for like a good three years, so.
I mean, it seems like she already enjoys it.
So that's a good sign.
That's that's all I wanted to do.
That's the only thing that put a smile on my face.
Maybe in a couple of years,
we can upgrade to some pots and pans.
(Marcel and audience laughing)
Yeah.
Sounds perfect and doable.
Marcel, I'm so grateful that you and Lane came by.
I'm so glad your video went viral.
I think it went viral because it's bringing everybody joy
and that's what we need right now
as well as your heroic service.
Thank you for taking care of us.
Oh no, thank you for having me, it's been a pleasure,
it's been awesome.
And Travis, I just, again want to thank you so much
for our awesome time together.
(Travis laughs)
And Travis's wonderful company, Barker Wellness,
which is gorgeous and effective
and beautifully thought out is available now.
And it'll be up on our website as well,
directing you to his website.
So thank you for coming and telling us about that.
Awesome, thank you.
All right, thank you so much.
(upbeat music)